we know that we've not imagined these
attacks we know that we are bruised and
infected and Pregnant and some of us are
dead inspired by a true story a group of
women are tasked with deciding what
action to take after discovering the men
in their religious Colony have been
drugging and raping the female members
for years
its themes of misogyny and power are
pertinent especially perhaps to its star
Claire Foy following a highly publicized
court case during which a man pleaded
guilty to stalking her I don't think
women do need to be protected or looked
after I think we're all quite capable I
mean our greatest myself but of looking
after ourselves it's at the world that
we live in doesn't agree
um and that that's why so many women and
young girls are put into such dangerous
and maybe
um uh situations that are very similar
to this movie
um I think that the film is really
interesting because I think it deals
with power and how power affects people
do nothing stay in front this is set in
a remote devout Community but perhaps as
we hear so much about violence against
women still resonates within our own
Society I think one of the things the
film's about is that the patriarchy
doesn't serve men either like it's not a
happy situation for anybody I think
that's very important to understand I
think the the way we can kind of move
forward is through conversation and
allowing all of all of us to change each
other you know constructively rather
than kind of aggressively in a way women
talking is up for best picture and best
adapted screenplay at the Oscars but it
was overlooked in the best director
category which this year has an all-male
shortlist many think an oversight by the
academy as Hollywood continues to face
pressure to ensure equality in the
industry Canadian director Sarah Polly
says the lack of female nominees isn't
the half of it for me the biggest
disappointment in that category was
there is an opportunity to have the
first black woman ever nominated for an
Oscar the directing category and that
opportunity wasn't taken so when I think
about movies like till or the woman king
or say no like there there were a lot of
options so this story seemingly
representative of the inequality that
continues to dominate The Narrative
behind the scenes in Hollywood
Claire Gregory Sky News